die lage in syrien ist hochexplosiv doch
für die rund eine halbe million opfer
inzwischen interessiert sich
mittlerweile kaum noch jemand denn wir
hier sind ja nicht direkt beteiligt vor
einem möglichen dritten weltkrieg
dagegen der uns alle treffen würde
fürchtet sich die ganze welt doch wie
würde ein dritter weltkrieg aussehen und
wodurch könnte ausgelöst werden
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle
wichtigen facts zu diesem hochbrisanten
thema herzlich willkommen bei pixum
science fiction
wenn man denkt dass der hochexplosive
konflikt in und um syrien lediglich
regional ist täuscht man sich gewaltig
immer wieder würde in diesem kontext in
diesem zusammenhang auch darüber
spekuliert ob die lage dort früher oder
später zu einem möglichen dritten
weltkrieg eskalieren kann erst jetzt hat
sich ein russischer armeegeneral dazu
geäußert demnach sei die lage noch nicht
reif für einen dritten weltkrieg da die
politiker noch genug verstand besitzen
würden dieses zu verhindern denn das
sind nur männer die für die großen
verantwortlich nationen stehen da muss
es sich um einen wahren optimisten
handeln
gerade noch hat donald trump mit einem
raketenangriff gedroht wahnsinn denn
viele verschiedene parteien mit
unterschiedlichen interessen sind
involviert und das macht es nicht
harmloser das horrorszenario eine
russische angriff auf amerikanische
einsatzkommandos oder eben umgekehrt
diese drohung steht im raum egal ob aus
versehen oder mit voller absicht wenn
das passiert dann ist die große frage
wie die usa oder eben russland reagieren
die daraus resultierende eskalation
könnte weit über syrien hinausgehen an
sehr vielen staatsspitzen stehen nicht
ruhige besonnene politiker sondern eben
gerade das gegenteil und jeweils steht
in einem solchen konflikt ihre macht auf
dem spiel
eine sehr gefährliche situation viele
experten experten sehen tatsächlich vor
allem russland als möglichen auslöser
für eine weltweite eskalation demnach
könnte der syrien-konflikt das ende vom
anfang sein und in einem wesentlich
größeren ausmaß enden nämlich in einem
krieg zwischen russland und der nato
schon jetzt sprechen manche experten der
experten bezüglich des verhältnisses des
westens zu russland von einem zweiten
kalten krieg und über den krieg der
zukunft nachzudenken und zu schreiben
genau das ist der job des us strategen
of cool
seiner meinung nach würde ein dritter
weltkrieg beginnen ohne dass wir es
bemerken würden denn der auslöser für
die weltweite eskalation sei nicht
unbedingt die zerstörung einer stadt
oder ein militärischer angriff auf eine
bestimmte region kohl ist überzeugt
davon ein dritter weltkrieg ist kein
zweiter weltkrieg nur mit modernen
waffen kohl zufolge ist dagegen eine
attacke im weltraum viel
wahrscheinlicher als ein möglicher
kriegs auslöser ein satellit der die
kommunikation und navigation einer
region
sicherstellt hätte dann plötzlich und
dann plötzlich ausfällt und mit dem gps
mobilfunk und internet an land plötzlich
genauso angreifbar und verletzlich wie
sein militär und die einwohner genauso
denkbar seien erste attacken im
cyberspace also hacker angriffe auf
wichtige ziele wie etwa das militär
börsen oder sonstige wichtige
einrichtungen die das zusammenleben und
die sicherheit eines landes
gewährleisten sollen
fest steht jedenfalls die treibenden
kräfte eines möglichen dritten
weltkriegs sind die atommächte
und dann bleibt da nur zu hoffen dass
sie sich bewusst sind darüber welche
wahnsinnigen konsequenzen deren einsatz
hätte dennoch die atomwaffen werden als
letztes mittel werden sie alle im
hinterkopf haben und donald m hat ja
auch schon darüber gesprochen ja und vor
allem wenn großstädte krankenhäusern
zivilisten angegriffen werden vielleicht
würde dies aber auch bewusst vermieden
werden und hauptkampf gebiete auf weiter
entfernte regionen eingegrenzt werden
die berühmten stellvertreterkriege in
einem dritten weltkrieg könnten zudem
internationale gremien dazu dienen
diplomatisch vorzugehen und als
kommunikationskanal zwischen den gegnern
zu agieren manche experten experten
gehen davon aus dass ein möglicher
dritter weltkrieg sogar über einige
jahrzehnte dauern könnte
der grund dafür die ressourcen werden
nicht sehr schnell erschöpft sein
anders als im totalen krieg werden wohl
nicht alle jungen männer der beteiligten
länder mobilisiert und es werden wohl
auch nicht alle zur verfügung stehenden
waffen eingesetzt
so könnten die menschen eventuell lernen
mit dem krieg zu leben eine furchtbare
vision
anfang des jahres hat ein us
mathematiker eine große datenmenge
analysiert und einen möglichen zeitpunkt
für den ausbruch des dritten weltkriegs
errechnet demnach ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit für einen globalen
bewaffneten konflikt hoch der studie
zufolge wird noch bis zum jahr 2100 50
ein großer zwischenstaatlicher konflikt
ausbrechen da ist bei all den ganzen ja
spannenden vermutung muss man sagen aber
auch keine forschungsgruppe dieser welt
kann in die glaskugel sehen und wie ein
krieg am ende beginnt und verläuft ist
sicher von vielen verschiedenen faktoren
abhängig aber eines scheint sich immer
mehr heraus zu kristallisieren
wenn wir noch in den 80er und 90er
jahren
geglaubt haben dass die welt immer
vernünftiger wird und deshalb einige
jahrhunderte dauernde friedensperiode
naht sind diese friedenspartner 7
inzwischen verflogen an das war ja
damals die die großen friedens und die
großen abrüstungsverträge zwischen den
großen mächten nato und udssr wenn er es
neues aus dem bereich politik
wissenschaft und zu allen anderen themen
erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
und zu beginn gibt es noch ein kleines
kunden als dankeschön wenn er euch dort
anmeldet einfach draufklicken und
natürlich nicht das abo mit der genauso
locker vergesst nie geht es weiter mit
dafür auch drauf klicken
so wäre ein atomkrieg ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran